welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and it's been a
pretty big weekend to be a DC fan with
the Joker getting tens across the board
and now the birds of prey trailer has
leaked online after being shown at the
extended cut of spider-man far from home
this trailer was rumored to be releasing
with a chapter two later this week which
would have made sense as it's a Warner
Brothers film but I guess Sony wanted to
give people a reason to go back and
watch their directors car after all the
controversy that's been going on with
spider-man in the last couple of weeks
the birds of prey and the fantabulous
emancipation of one harley quinn you're
giving it its full title sees the return
of Harley Quinn and the trailer has a
lot to break down from it throughout
this video I'll be going over everything
that you need to know about this new
look as well as giving my thoughts on
what the movie could be about there will
be heavy spoilers here so if you wanna
wait til the trailer is officially
released online then I highly suggest
that you turn off now without the way I
just want to give a huge thank you for
clicking this video now let's get into
my breakdown of the birds of prey
trailer okay so the trailer is actually
pretty similar to the first look that we
got a couple of months ago on the film
it's very fast and frantic
I feel is the right word and there's a
lot of shots of the characters in it and
what they look like and that's roughly
about 20 seconds so there's not a
massive amount that we can take from it
but there's lots of little shots that
I'll be breaking down throughout this
video so the trailer opens with the DC
logo and some red balloons again this
would have made sense to drop before hit
chapter 2 and I have a feeling that they
would have done it this way you had Sony
maybe not offered them some extra money
at the last minute but this balloon sort
of becomes a motif for the introduction
of the trailer and they even reference
penny wise directly when Harley Quinn
pops on screen and says I've had enough
of these clowns this kind of cements the
whole it release thing for me and whilst
you can take it as her referring to the
Joker I wouldn't be surprised if it
emerged that this was meant to come out
with the chapter 2 release to kind of
create some synergy between the two
brands we then get another close-up of
Harley Quinn and her new look which is
sort of an evolution of how she dressed
in the Suicide Squad
actually preferred the daddy's little
monster look over this but it's kind of
a different step with the character
which as we know from the title of the
film will be highly focused on her and
her emancipation emancipation pretty
much means a social movement to gain
rights and I think this film will be
centered around her breaking away from
the abusive relationship that she was in
with the Joker and Suicide Squad and
sort of taking her own measures to
become her own person we then cut to a
motorcycle being rode through what looks
like Gotham and on top of it is Mary
Elizabeth Winstead who is playing the
Huntress in the trailer she fires a
crossbow and this is sort of her
signature weapon now for those who don't
know the Huntress depending on which
origin story you follow is either the
daughter of a mob boss or Batman and
Catwoman have a feeling that they may
change this up for the film to be the
daughter of black mask played by you
McGregor and she's sort of a vigilante
that does good throughout Gotham next we
see Black Canary kicking a guy and again
this is a reinforcement of strong women
which ties back to the title and I think
this will sort of be the creation of the
first female superhero group which is of
course what the birds of prey are we
then get some shots of you McGregor as
black mask or rather sionis at this
point he isn't wearing his most defining
character trade so I think in this movie
he will start off as the gangster say
honest before adopting the moniker black
mask later in the movie as things sort
of heat up for the character he's at a
club where black Canary is singing and
she could be using this as a guise to
infiltrate his lair and find out exactly
what he's up to in the city there's a
mannequin with hands in the club and we
see a couple of times that the
characters interact with these
throughout the trailer including Harley
Quinn and Cassandra Cain who was seen
fighting amongst T's Harley Quinn pulls
a finger off and throws it at someone so
it seemed like this will be a big action
set piece we then see Rosie Perez with
Huntress and the Black Canary and she
fights someone whilst the other members
battle people in the background before
we could Harley Quinn eating a hamburger
and she winks at the camera she's
wearing a jacket with two hyenas on
which fans of the character will know
are her to pets bud and Lou they're
pretty frightening and if they make an
appearance in the movie I think that it
would be a really unnerving way to take
down villains now there are rumors that
the movie centers around Black Mask who
is gay apparently and that the story is
about him getting back a sex tape that
people are using the blackmail him
whether this turns out to be true we
will see but I don't really know if it's
the best route to take with a comic book
movie personally That's not me having
anything against gay people or whatever
I think if if it was a straight sex tape
I'd still be like why is a sex tape in a
comic book film and I get that DC are
trying to be unique and progressive but
I'm personally not that sure if it's a
good plot motif to really set a comic
book film around
I'm guessing this will be adult only and
the sort of going after the mature
comic-book audience which we do know is
out there due to the success of Deadpool
and Logan it's quite a unique plot
device I guess I mean I can't see this
popping up in a Marvel movie but it
looks like DC along with this and Joker
are kind of finally embracing what makes
their characters and universe unique
it'll be interesting to see if they can
pull it off I actually wasn't massively
disappointed with the Suicide Squad so
it'll be good to see if this helps to
set up the events of that sequel though
I doubt it
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the birds of prey and the fantabulous
emancipation of Harley Quinn 1 Harley
Quinn I don't know what it's called and
if you're looking forward to the film or
not comment below and let me know and if
you enjoyed this video then please give
it a thumbs up and make sure you check
out my full breakdown of the extended
curve spider-man far from home I got
over all of the added scenes and give my
thoughts on the release so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want to know more if you want to come
talk to me about movies TV shows games
and comic books then you can follow me
on twitter at definition whitey it's the
best way to get in touch with me and
it's the perfect place to suggest new
videos and content so hopefully I see
you over there after this I also just
want to let you know that we're giving
away a free copy of John wick 3 on
blu-ray and all you have to do to be in
with a chance of winning is to like this
video make sure that you subscribe to
the channel and leave your thoughts and
the birds of prey trailer in the comment
section below the winner will be chosen
at random on September the 10th and the
blu-ray will be shipped out from then to
ever get surprised it's the best of luck
to everyone
part this is a channel for people who
are super into superheroes so if that's
the kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you